سالنا ناس هل حالتك النفسيه سيئه تحسن من
ادائك الوظيفي نتابع الاجابات
بس في دراسه امريكيه صدرت مؤخرا بطول
العكس انه بس تكون نفسيتك تعبانه النشاطك
بالشغل بيزيد شو رايك يعني اذا هن مش
عايشين بلبنان راح يقدروا يفهموا نحن كيف
قد ايه عم نمرق بقصص كل يوم بصير في مشاكل
وهلا قصه الزلازل
انا كشخصة وعشرين سنه اصعب شيء علي اشتغل
او نفسيتها تعبانه لا بقدر مضبوط ولا
مزبوط عرفته فانا هيك بحس بحس انه انت جيت
العمل هي بتاثر علي اكثر شيء المدخول
تبعها فاذا كان المدخول ان كان نفسيتك
تعبانه او نفسيتك هو المدخول هو اللي بقرر
اذا انت مبسوطه بشغلك بتقدري تعطي بتعطي
نفس العطاء
اذا عندك مدخول ماده عم يعمل لكشن
لالك ولا حياتك هلا ممكن حسب الشغل حسب
نوعيه الشغل يمكن اذا كانت نفسيتك تعبانه
بكون في عندك غضب جواتك ممكن شغلك بده
تكون انت مثلا تستعمل شي يدوي او شيء ممكن
تعطي انتاجيه اكثر لانه اعصابك بتكون
شاديه اكثر بس بالغالب لا لما بتكون
نفسيتك تعبانه ما بتشتغل منيح بتخف
انتاجيتك يمكن ما بتيجي على الشغل اصلا